sa veuve d'une trentaine d'années il
c'était la voix de l'ordinateur
macintosh au moment de sa présentation
officielle par steve jobs
aurait marre qu'ils aiment à
l'enthousiasmé de la foule ils ont
entendu un ordinateur incroyable mais
vrai et on va parler avec janick
tremblay s'était pas un hasard cet
enthousiasme et leurs quelque chose
qui était vraiment pas pareil aux autres
qui introduisait pour commencer une
interface graphique donc avec les tuiles
si vous voulez qu'ils se promenaient
lens mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'était tout en un aussi avec un écran
de 9 pouces
et l'ordinateur pesant huit kilos avec
un lecteur de disque 3 pouces et demi ce
que j'aime pour les chiffres mais parce
qu'à l'époque c'était les disquettes
canton à la veste et des 5 pouces etc a
rappelé les grosses disque est souple
sur ce plan c'est prenant le témoin même
si vous voulez pas vous en souvenez avec
un écran monochrome de 512 par 342 noir
sur blanc donc parce qu'on est habitués
écran noir avec du verre ou du orange
non l'on changeait complètement de
registre le new york times à l'époque le
chroniqueur techno parlait d'une image
vraiment très nette vraiment être très
clair aujourd'hui on a deux du 2560
parmi les quatre cent quarante sur un
écran de 27 pouces et vous donner une
idée jamais partout vu comme l'inde ou
la mémoire est 128 kg bate excusez moi
et là en état
giga octets voilà mais quand même on
avait un design qui jetait les bases
d'une nouvelle informatique on est
vraiment un côté très geek en ce moment
là on veut l'assumer prix de vente 2500
$ donc c'est à peu près 5000 de nos
dollars aujourd'hui c'est créer cher
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est presque pas
possible de payer serait étonnant pour
un ordinateur à moins d'acheter un mac
pro hl qui m'aiment pas encore sur le
marché est encore là je pense pas que ça
va et surtout il y avait une souris ce
qui était du jamais vu à l'époque c'est
la première souris mais celle là elle
avait été développé par 0 oui vous avez
raison mais qui avait été intégré par
steve jobs et toute sa bande
il avait il été rendu au parc s'étaient
rendus au parc d'expérience de xerox
avait vu sa belle allure vont faire son
auto 6 qui a fait si vous avez lu la
biographie de walter isaacson de job et
ça c'est le vol du si
donc on va faire un petit voyage dans le
temps avec eux de nos collègues philippe
qui bruno st pierre qui est animateur de
l'émission et donc du matin à rimouski
c'est un grand fan la marque apple et
c'est le cofondateur du club à bâle dans
le bas-du-fleuve rentrer à l'époque au
likoud et on se souvient pour certains
on était impressionné d'abord par la
souris l'interface on n'avait jamais
appris à communiquer autrement que par
un clavier avec un ordinateur là on
avait cette souris et puis c'est un peu
comme un jeune enfant qui utilise une
souris pour la première fois on déplace
le curseur dans le mauvais sens on
savait patrons comprenaient pas trop il
y avait aussi ces menus qui déroulait
cette interface graphique on était
habitué à a programmé des codes des
nuits temps pour arriver à faire des
choses et là tout d'un coup c'était
simple c'était facile c'était convivial
ça nous amenait énormément de créativité
piste un peu la philosophie d'apple
depuis le début de steve jobs c'était de
dire il faut qu'on enlève la barrière
entre l'utilisateur et la créativité
l'ordinateur et doit laisser s'exprimer
la créativité des gens la mise en page
le dessin avec ma crainte le traitement
texte avec macwrite ça nous a ouvert des
possibilités immenses
quelque chose
truc reconnaissez vous en rappelez quand
même en commun on était pression' et par
cette machine là et c'est vrai que ça
pouvait ouvrir les vannes de la
créativité et le penser à toutes les
polices de caractères puisqu'ils étaient
inconnus quand on tapait sur un pc les
chicago les new york les grands littell
des clients souligné là dès que ça c'est
arrivé certains sont bien les utiliser
un peu trop vous demander
dans un même document avec 4 police de
caractère mais auparavant vous le dire
c'était impossible c'était des outils
des formats qui était réservé au milieu
de l'édition d'ailleurs on a vu des
journaux internes d'entreprise est aussi
dans les écoles
journaux qui se sont transformées quand
ils sont arrivés ces ordinateurs là il
ya eu ce qu'on pourrait appeler un effet
whaou et c'est ce qui a permis à apple
de se bâtir une communauté de fans
encore une fois on regarde dans le
rétroviseur 30 ans en arrière avec bruno
saint pierre je dirais que c'est presque
une religion il y avait des autobus
nolisés pour aller une fois par année au
macworld à bostens chercher les
dernières nouveautés les gens revenaient
les bras pleins de logiciels de nouveaux
trucs qu'on pouvait utiliser d'interface
qu'on pouvait connectés on était très
content on avait des conférenciers pour
quelques jours rien je la salle était
pleine et beaucoup de questions et non
c'était une autre époque il n'y avait
pas l'internet à ce moment là
aujourd'hui c'est facile vous cliquez
sur votre souris et puis vous allez
chercher un logiciel sur le app store en
quelques minutes mais ce n'est pas si
simple on n'avait même pas l'internet à
l'époque
à prendre essaye d'expliquer ça
quelqu'un qui a moins de 30 ans
aujourd'hui nous regarde avec les yeux
voilà bon mais justement à bord le monde
a changé steve jobs est mort qu'est ce
qui reste des valeurs qui ont mené au
lancement c'est une question qui est
intéressante parce que les possibilités
avec des ordinateurs maintenant il
manque beaucoup plus grande grâce à
internet justement les mac d'aujourd'hui
sont un peu plus compliquées à
configurer que chef d'une secte avait
cadré blues de l'application maintenant
il est aussi faut le dire malgré tout
quand on pense à tous les produits
d'apple il faut conclure qu' ils sont
c'est très fortement ancrée dans l'adn
si on veut de la compagnie tout ça parce
que le imac vous le branchez vous le
connecter à internet et tout de suite il
vous dit bonjour ça fonctionne quand
même évidemment il ya des réglages je
vais faire après mais ça va quand même
essayer il avait fonctionné tout de
suite ni pensée ou iphone ou ipod ou
ipad avec les écrans tactiles vous savez
c'est une simplicité d'utilisation
lui-même être des arts manque donc
encore une fois c'est la recherche de
l'interface la plus simple et la plus
conviviale sas est resté et ça a
contribué à l'émergence y ont vu et la
multiplication des mobinautes et si on
étire le champ de réflexion penser à la
télé d'abord penser à la confidence que
steve jobs a fait oui moi je les
trouvais la solution ils ont pas encore
commercialisé c'est lé l'heure toujours
pas au point pensez à la montre
connecter toutes les compagnies en salle
mais toujours pas apple même si l'on dit
que ça lise intéressait on fait monter
les enchères on cherche le meilleur
produit aussi mais au delà du marketing
et des formules des publicitaires moi je
pense en tout cas que la devise la pause
ça pourrait ressembler à ce que moi je
dis souvent mes enfants ce qu'ils
méritent des faits méritent d'être bien
fait parce que c'est le cas des produits
apple il faut le dire ils seront peu à
l'occasion mais c'est pas parce qu'ils
essaient pas est la première
manifestation évidente de ce principe là
ça a été le macintosh en 1915 un produit
convivial beaucoup plus que les autres
d'époque et un beau produit c'était
boulsa bcbg tête et c'est un superbe
aubin
l'exemple au vent